this is obviously some sort of
prayer it's obviously not a Christian
prayer so one can only imagine which uh
supposed deities she's invoking okay now
she's breathing on her hands that
doesn't seem very cautious with Co and
oh there we go she coughed on one of the
panelists faces they're obviously just
messing with us because we led the
charge of saying wear face masks don't
you can't ever cough you can't breathe
now she's just coughing a mix
of her presumably bacteria ridden breath
but also at the spiritual level who
knows what kind of spirits it's weird
the lady in question here Styles herself
an indigenous Shaman which is just the
PC term for witch and it's nothing new
for all of human history prideful Elites
have been inclined toward the ridiculous
occult worship of false gods the
indigenous tribes all did it the
Canaanites did it even the Israelites
did it when Moses left them to their own
devices for five minutes in the desert